10/ 10 pour Montini le breteneux
l'équipe senior continue son sans faute
dans le championnat de première série
leur victime du jour le stade reince 5e
du classement avant la rencontre le
rouleau compresseur inimontin a réussi à
remporter la victoire dans la douleur 16
à 10 au stade de Roger couder sur un
terrain lourd on est passé pas loin de
la correctionnelle face à une équipe de
reince vaillante et sur un terrain lourd
on avit donné des consignes aux joueurs
qui ont pas forcément été respectés et
puis on sait que le rugby ça passe par
par du jeu devant à la base voilà donc
voilà on a les quatre points donc c'est
le principal et ça nous permet de
continuer à travailler sereinement on a
pas réussi à développer vraiment notre
rugby euh on a joué bah pas comme on
aurait dû le faire et et puis du coup
bah ça ça donne un match Eré avec avec
un groupe d'avance chez eux qui était
très très solide très costaud et qui
était plutôt avantagé sur ce genre de
terrain avec cette victoire Montini le
bretonux s'offre un boulevard pour
terminer premier du classement de cette
pouune les inimontins comptent 13 points
d'avance sur le gangerville mais les
coach tentent de garder les joueurs sous
pression les joueurs on les lâche pas et
puis on rappelle nos objectifs nos
objectifs qui sont de finir premier
invaincu et puis d'accéder à cette
demi-finale de championnat de France
sachant que la montée est quasi quasi
faite pour valider le plus vite possible
cette première place les joueurs de
Montini le bretonux tenteront
d'accrocher stetin à leur tableau de
chasse le match est programmé le 19
février prochain à
15h